I called my father
and
instead of saying hello
he said you son of let's look at Hebrew
what xipa means okay let's look what
happened and there it is look I'm gonna
click play listen very carefully listen
to how it sounds like
Hira
illiterate saying please read this he'll
say I cannot read this is this is
literally what Muslims believe wow so
he's threatening you with the
inheritance now that's it all the money
is going to be gone it's either Islam or
it's us and remember I told you that
I've I've been raised like
very very well off out of my whole
lineage which comes from Norway he said
you know your inheritance you know that
the house you know the house and the
land and everything
foreign
brothers and sisters as you can see
we've acquired the property and we're
getting right to work and with your duas
and support we can go ahead and get the
Masjid and meghadawa Center up open and
running in sha Allah imagine every
person that prays here gets educated and
guided to Islam here you'll get a part
of all those blessings and rewards insha
Allah what are you waiting for brothers
and sisters you're going to leave it all
behind anyway so go ahead and invest in
your Hereafter that's Everlasting click
the link below donate right now may God
Almighty Allah reward all of you
hello
[Music]
subscribe if you haven't already so you
don't miss exciting episodes and stories
like this one with my next guest for the
first 19 years of his life he was a
Christian things started to change for
him when he was seven years old when he
entered the church for the first time
and witnessed people speaking in tongues
running down the aisles and rolling on
the floor it scared him as a child and
then now at the age of 14 years old he
was going to the church three days a
week Wednesday's Bible study Friday
youth night and Sunday's church but one
night at Bible study everything took a
turn when he found certain
contradictions in the Bible and when he
asked his teacher about these
contradictions he was told just to
believe and have faith without getting
the answers to his questions he
continued from that point on being a
Christian from the outside but his
belief on the inside was gone
he goes by the name of Maliki click and
he's here to let us know more about his
journey and what happened next
[Applause]
alive
and his final message is Muhammad peace
be upon him this is our religion Islam
Islam this is the teacher
and I was explaining how much respect I
have for the faith of Islam
welcome to the beach
foreign
nice to meet you nice to meet you too
brother how you been alhamdulillah
everything is good alhamdulillah so
let's get right into your journey so for
the first 19 years of Christian and then
talk to us about this experience now as
a child seven years old
you walk in and what happens
I walked into the church and it was just
like you know as a seven-year-old child
you know you picture church as this
quiet place and you know you sing a
couple of hymns and whatnot but I go in
as a seven-year-old child and I see
people just crying and running up and
down the aisles and rolling on you know
around on the floor and speaking a
language that I've never heard before
and it just it really scared the hell
out of me so I actually I was holding my
dad's hand I actually ripped away and
tried to run out of the church at that
moment
but it got me back you know he he held
my hand and said no no this is this is
church but I mean honestly the whole
thing was extremely intimidating and I
was just lost I didn't know what was
going on as a cat as a kid uh for our
audience that has no idea what do you
mean by this speaking its own let's go
ahead and show some footage so they can
get a better uh feel and understanding
to uh when you say talking in tongues
what do we actually mean again
[Applause]
foreign foreign
[Music]
what's happening something similar
because you have different things happen
in different churches but we saw people
speaking what some kind of be gibberish
and then people fall in rolling on the
floor and
is this what you were saying well those
clips were actually a little bit tame to
what I was in you know that was tame
yeah that was like the diet version like
when I went it was I mean imagine you
know those clips even though like a
seven-year-old experiencing that for the
first time uh but yeah that was that was
like that was only like 60 of what I
um experienced in the church
later was it um made clear to you what
that was did you later figure that out
I was told because I asked my Dad what's
wrong with these people you know why are
they you know crying and shouting and
you know even people would stand up as
if they were messengers of God and you
know I I say unto you people I have a
message from the Lord and I'm just
looking at the person like
like what what is this person talking
about now this is crazy but yeah I was
told that it was a spiritual language
it's it's a it's a holy language from
God that nobody understood except God
and I'm thinking to myself you know
later on you know when I was like 14
years old well if it's a language how
come y'all can't understand each other
you know if if a person speaks Spanish
to another Spanish-speaking person
they're going to understand but this is
just gibberish 110 gibberish
not a hundred percent 110 so you think
uh you think you think um
you think uh Jay what's his name this is
JD this is a famous uh Christian
preacher you know who this is right yeah
yeah what's his name
I I don't I know who he is I know I know
his face but I don't know his name yeah
JD Blake's or something anyways uh do
you think he's conscious like of what
he's doing do you think he's just making
up things is he as he goes along he
knows that this is gibberish because
there's Christians who call this out
also many who will say like this is this
is uh they'll say it Christians will say
this is a gibberish
[Music]
I don't understand the single thing I
think you were saying because this is
not the biblical interpretation I keep a
silence in the church
they don't even know what it is
it's so obviously not what it was in the
scripture
I mean look this is what it is it's
gibberish they don't know what they're
saying
um they're just trying to bring a
spiritual Aura to the church but at the
end of the day I know you know a lot of
other Christians know that Christianity
well the church is just a huge Cash Cow
it's all about entertainment it's all
about you know um
charging people's Iman if you want to
call it for Sunday so they'll give more
it's just a big production nothing more
um
and then uh you went on from there so
you had this experience it's kind of
traumatizing would you say and then uh
what did you mean actually when your
father when he gave himself you said he
gave himself to Christ as you define it
what did it actually mean
well I I think what he means is he
turned his life around for Christ he
started to have a moral compass in his
life
per the Bible so that that's that's what
I think that's what I I think he means
because we believe in Christ I mean the
Messiah translated
um right from the Greeks this is the
name given to Jesus the Messiah we
believe you believe that now as a Muslim
don't you of course 110 yeah and you
love Jesus I mean without a doubt you
can't be a Muslim unless you love and
Revere Jesus not as a God or literal Son
of God but as a messenger of God
so um we follow the way of Jesus
which was uh calling people to worship
the Creator not the creation so
um Jesus was a Muslim wow uh what do
people say when you say that Jesus was a
Muslim do you get a lot of pushback
people are like what are you talking
about and how do you how do you uh
explain that because some people will
say right away well Islam came later
um he was a Christian what are you
talking about how would you can you go
ahead and unpackage that for us I I get
pushed back all the time I have a
YouTube I have a YouTube and a tick tock
Channel and a lot of people even say I
mean here's the thing
Christians don't know anything about
Islam yet they say that it's wrong right
so I've even had like I showcase really
dumb comments that I get on my Tick Tock
and people are saying oh
um
Allah came they even say Allah Allah
came 570 years after Christianity that
means that it I'm just thinking wow
buddy like you do you really really
think that the you know we know as
Muslims and I know both sides of the
coin
being a Christian for the first 19 years
of my life and a Muslim for 31 years now
I know both sides of the coin and so
they don't know both sides of the coin
and so when you say that Jesus was a
Muslim and that you say that all the
unbiya or all the prophets were Muslim
they just don't get it they just don't
get it because they believe that they're
the circus you know they're they're the
same sect and nobody uh you know can can
attain salvation except through Jesus
and what we're saying is Muslims is um
how come the message of Jesus is so
unique to all of the prophets and if
Jesus was sent
to die you know his whole message was
was true how come all of the other
prophets that came before him and the
one that came after him
don't affirm that how come their message
is here is the Lord your God is one you
know Jesus said that here ye Israel the
Lord your God is one because you know
the Scribe came to him and so said oh
Master tell us the most important of the
of the laws because Jesus was speaking
in the temple and everybody all eyes are
on him and people were impressed with
him and he said
hear ye Israel the Lord your God is one
now if he was God if he was a Son of God
if salvation was attained through him
only
this would be his perfect opportunity to
say hear ye Israel the Lord your God is
Father Son and Holy Spirit and the only
way that you can attain salvation is
through me but that's the point he
didn't say that hear ye Israel the Lord
your God is one
uh-huh so by saying that he was a Muslim
you're saying he was a submitter to God
to one God so people say yes they'll
agree with that but Muslim just defines
that term submitter to God one who
submitted to the will of God it defines
it exactly that's what it is yeah that
is really profound and deep I mean if
people really reflect and think about it
and you are actually someone who was
going to what three times a week so
you're going to a Bible study you're
going to uh the church and you're also
going to the youth groups correct yes
sir yes sir and you were doing that for
quite some time for years huh yeah I
mean that's the way I was brought up you
know it was just you know go to the to
the church three days a week and that
was my life
talk to us about that what were some of
the things that you were learning there
was it um was it something that you're
you were cementing your belief did you
always have doubts did it come all of a
sudden
please uh elaborate on that I always
believed in God as a young man I always
knew that there was
um a higher power and
but the thing with me in in the church
and in the youth group
is I I never really latched on to Jesus
being God as a child I always saw him as
a father figure a mentor somebody to be
like
um when you need inspiration or you know
what should I do with my life you know
the thought is what would Jesus do and
so
um I I never really professed that he
was God
100 of my heart you know when when we
are Muslims we our hearts you know have
yaquin and we say
we negate all other things of worship
except Allah and we affirm illallah
except Allah so yeah I mean I was I was
just jumping through the Hoops
um
because here's the thing with a lot of
Americans and myself
there's nothing else
um you know I was I was raised like
you know very well off my whole family
is in petroleum you know my father and
my uncle my brothers everybody and so I
didn't want for anything so I grew up in
this white bubble of Christianity and so
that was what you were supposed to be if
you're a white American you are supposed
to be Christian you cannot be this you
cannot be that no this is what you're
supposed to be and so we accepted and a
lot of American citizens accept it
because that's what they think that's
that's all there is so there's nowhere
else to go I can't go to those the brown
religion over here the the Islamic
people I can't do that because I'm you
know I I'm white but you know
where was Christianity from Detroit
Michigan no it's it's from the Middle
East so
but that's not something that's um
uncommon you had certain polls that were
done that a great number of Christians
actually don't believe Jesus Is God
they're going in line with their fitra
their innate nature that he was a human
being they would be in line when you
talked I'm sure you talked to people if
they're sincere they're open-minded like
like you were at that time and you line
them up with all the other Messengers
Moses Abraham Noah that goes in line
that makes sense that he was a messenger
not an actual literal God or a or a son
of God not a God or literal Son of God
so there's a a lot of Christians that
favor that and they don't believe that
he's actually God the do you hear about
this poll this uh this poll that was
done
no I didn't yeah we'll get it up here um
but yeah there was a poll that was done
so then so what happens the whole time
you're not really believing you're not
cemented that Jesus is God but you're
praying so you're praying to God the god
that Jesus prayed to you're not actually
praying to Jesus like we see in Jesus
name
father something
I'm I'm praying
and I'm just
the you know Eddie the
how can I say this I was constantly
looking I'm like I'm I'm waiting and I'm
looking for something to really enter my
heart and so I I just went to you know
Wednesday Bible study to strengthen my
you know my my Bible skills and you know
learn more about God and the prophets
and stuff like that and uh I'm just it's
like I was it's hard to explain but I'm
just like waiting for something to
happen where I can just like
have the aha moment or something or you
know uh have that Iman burst or whatever
you want to call it being a Christian
but I never got it you know quite the
opposite especially when I was 14 years
old at the Bible study
so I can guarantee you I'm sure there's
a lot of uh Christians right now and
again we're never trying to disrespect
people or their faith or anything just
trying to uh bring certain things to
light that they can ponder and probably
reflect upon and probably relate to and
they're probably a lot relating to what
you just said what about the crucifixion
what about the crucifixion what was your
stance on that did you believe now that
when you create when you would do sins
you were just like well Jesus Paid for
him and
um you would you would
um feel that now his blood was a
Redemption for your sins via the
crucifixion
the way I looked at the crucifixion
especially in my younger years you know
from 7 to 14 is I always wondered
why does why does somebody have to die
why why when you know we take the
communion why are we drinking the blood
of Jesus why are we eating the body of
Christ what what's happening here you
know what and I and that's I think
that's the thing that you know I was
trying to explain I didn't get that
relationship with with God I was always
told well you got to go through Jesus
and I always thought as a little boy
but why why can't I just go to God and
the Trinity forget it uh that that
didn't make any in any any sense at all
but uh yeah uh the crucifixion I never
really believed in it I never really
latched on to it and
you know the biggest thing is why did
somebody have to Die For What mm-hmm
so you got all these things going on in
your mind your heart but finally
something happened these two
contradictions or more something about
contradictions happen you went and you
asked your teacher what about him he
didn't he didn't even know they were in
the Bible and then you talk about how
just from the outside you're Christian
but the inside it was gone talk about
this
um I went to a Bible study one night on
Wednesday and we usually get to
um read 15 minutes before we get into
the lesson of the Bible preacher or the
the Bible leader Bible study leader and
so I'm reading and I'm just you know
thumbing through thumbing through doing
this just randomly and I come Acro I
come across a verse that says no man can
see God and live thereafter so in my
mind my fitra as a 14 year old boy I'm
thinking
sounds right
that sounds right because you know the
majesty and the glory of Allah or God in
that time
and then
I come to the story of Jacob
and here not only is Jacob seeing God
but he has a hold of the thigh of God
having a wrestling match with God and
I'm just thinking
what wait a minute over here it said
that no man
can see God
uh and and live after that and now Jacob
is having a wrestling match with God not
only that Jacob defeats God
and I'm just thinking
I raise my hand immediately and I say uh
to the Bible study leader
look at this verse over here it says
uh-huh yes yes and then I said well look
at this verse over here Jacob is having
and he said oh
you know I've I've heard of these
stories but uh yeah that I I didn't
really know that that was in there
you know and I'm just thinking
how can you not know how can you not
know a huge contradiction like that you
can't see God or you can see God you can
see God over here and have a wrestling
match and beat God but over here you
can't see him and live
and
so 14 year old me was like
[Music]
no I have a serious problem with this
and I'm not going to let this go
I need to rectify my heart right now
because I'm about to lose faith
and he said you know I don't know what
to tell you young man except that you
just gotta have faith
and at that moment I was just like
I don't want to have faith I'm tired of
just having faith in things that don't
make sense
I'm tired of having faith
and and the concept of someone needs to
die
for me to be forgiven
I'm I'm fed up and so you know I was
told you got to have faith you got you
just and he just told me I don't know
what to tell you I don't know how to
rectify your belief I don't know how to
calm your heart except to tell you that
you have to have faith and I just
no
No No so at 14 years old right then and
there at the Bible study I checked out
of Christianity and you know I still
live with my father my father's a very
strict Christian I couldn't listen to
music I couldn't have girlfriends you
know three days Church
and um
what can I say I jumped through the
Hoops of Christianity I continue to go
to church I continue to go to the youth
night and I continue to go to the Bible
study but nothing was here I completely
checked out
how did Islam jump into the equation did
you look into other religions and then
how did you get exposed to Islam
I never even heard about Islam and the
first Contact that I had of Islam well
kind of kind of a story to that I uh got
around
you know some some rough people got
around some wrong people and I actually
went to Maximum Security Prison
um
So I entered the prison system
and
I wasn't really looking for anything and
at the time before I went to prison and
even while I was in prison I had
absolutely no moral compass I mean I was
an animal I was wild I was a Savage I
didn't care about your life I didn't
care about my life I was just wild and
so I really wasn't looking for anything
except to just do my time and get out
so
I would say about three or four months
into my sentence
I I met a man who just randomly
approached me on the yard
called Omar and he was Turkish
and he approached me out of the blue I'm
just walking the track by myself Lone
Wolf in it
and he says amen I just want to ask you
something I just want to ask you a
question what do you know about Islam
and I said
I don't even know what that is because
again I grew up in my white bubble you
know uh you just don't talk about those
things those things don't exist because
in the Christian mind those things are
below and so everything is below and we
teach the world we are the standard of
what is right and wrong that's what they
say
so um
we walk the track and I'm a person of
nature I love the outdoors I'm an
Outdoorsman
um
and so he began to tell me you know
isn't it strange you know that that
Allah has put the sun 93 Million Miles
Away uh from the earth in Perfection you
know uh and
even though the sun is 93 million miles
away and the Moon is roughly 220 000
miles away look they meet and they cause
you know eclipses and stuff like that
and look at the creation the trees and
the ocean that Allah has created
everything for you and I told him about
and I just I was just like
okay okay this is different this is
different and so he used to just
um him and I used to meet out in the
yard and walk and talk
and
you know he would make his that one
and then
somehow I I got into this this combat
mode where
wait a minute so this guy is telling me
everything that I had learned
as a child
is wrong
hmm
okay
so I went to my Bible and I tried to
defend my Bible I tried to defend
Christianity I tried to uh defend my
belief right because this was totally
something new and totally something
foreign to me
but I couldn't
everything that I had every question
that I had he would smile and say
masha'allah it's a very good question
here's the answer and I just kept on
like
this guy has an answer for everything
not only does he have an answer it's
good not only does he has an answer it's
backed up by his book not only does he
have an answer it's backed up by
scientific proof as well
this might be what I've been looking for
my whole life
so I don't know do you want me to finish
the story yes please go into it okay so
him and I just always used to meet
outside in the yard
and you know he gave me one day he
showed up he said uh
I want to give you something from me to
you
but you have to make sure
that you wrap it up in a towel you take
it back to your cell and you keep it in
a clean place and I said
yeah sure man what is it
is I'm going to give you our holy book
I'm going to give you the Holy Quran
I said oh wow thank you yes I would love
I've never read the Quran before I would
love to
and so I took the quota on
back to my cell
and the first thing that I did
is I turned to the index
I mean I got this book in front of me
I'm thinking that it's going to be some
a thousand and one Arabian Nights type
of stuff you know I don't know
and I open up the index and I start
looking for names
Abraham Moses Jesus Mary Jacob
Ishmael Isaac Adam
sheath
all the stories were there and I just
thought oh
is it just like this book that I
rejected when I was 14 years old oh my
God it's just like the Bible oh
but then I read it and the first
the first
um I think Surah that I read was
attakatha
the things of this world
are dive are diverting you from the
truth and I just thought
that's me
I'm being diverted since I was raised so
well didn't want for anything
that's that's me
and so I kept on reading I kept on
reading a long story short I used to
read it every day so much so that my
cellmate
um told me he like gave me a nudge one
day he said hey man it's dinner time man
you come you coming out
and I said oh yeah like I snapped out a
bit I said man you've been reading that
book
sense of breakfast
and I said
have I
because I was just so engrossed
by
it's it's hard to put into words brother
but
the humanity
the truth
the realness
the answers
it's like I felt like I was getting the
real story that I wanted to find in the
Bible
now I found it and I found it
and it was put in a way where my heart
agreed with it and it understood
what it was saying when I would read the
Bible it was just like
bro what how can this I don't understand
how could this be
so my fetra as I read the Quran was just
like
ah yes yes yes yes
so
in my mind in the back of my mind I
considered what life would be like as a
Muslim
the shaytan entered the cell of the
maximum security State Prison that I was
at
you can't be a Muslim what are you
talking about the Aryan Brotherhood is
gonna do this and they're gonna look at
you weird and doing time alone is really
because everything Muslims might not
understand in the prison system it just
goes by race you don't have to agree
with it you don't have to like it or
dislike it that's what happens so I was
worried about all of these things you
know what is your family going to think
uh people are going to look at you like
you're you're like a wannabe like you're
pretending to be someone else all these
Whispers started to come
as soon as I imagine being a Muslim as
soon as my heart was like I love this
book
God finally a book that I can understand
finally a book
were you part of this uh Aryan
Brotherhood was this something no they
were just no it
no it when you get into the prison
system it's just like okay you seem to
be white okay they take your cot and
everything your your mattress and that
you know they give you things and they
instruct you okay look this is how we
roll you know we're up at five o'clock
in the morning and we exercise and you
gotta do it okay if something jumps off
we all jump you know if somebody jumps
we all jump we clear on that yeah so so
go back to what you were saying you soon
lose your point so you're saying the
Quran then what happened
yeah so months passed and we always Omar
and I always used to meet in the yard
and my arguments became less and less
until they were silent until I Was
Defeated until
I just listened and I soaked up whatever
he said so when we came out I would
listen and he would speak about what
Islam is
and I just uh
I was I was in a position of
okay God I would go back to my cell and
I would just say okay God
as I was waiting for something to happen
as a Christian I'm waiting for something
to happen now
I have always been true to myself to
embrace a truth wherever it came from so
if this is the truth let it happen let
something happen let something change
and so Omar came up to me one day and he
said
hey um
I was thinking about inviting you to
Juma
and uh I said what's Juma he said you
know Sunday church yep Sunday church for
Muslims we go on Friday
and so I actually had to uh fill out a
permission slip uh to go to Juma
and the CEO
uh the the the the
officer called me in his his office and
he just looked he just looked at me and
he said
um is this your name is this your your
uh your form right here asking
permission to go to Juma and I said yeah
yes sir and he said
do you know what Juma is
I said not really I'm just going to find
out and they said do you know who goes
to jummah
and I said sir
and he said uh you know black people go
to Juma and you know that you're gonna
be in the multi-purpose room with them
I said
yeah I know that
he said
what are you doing
and I said I just look it's my right as
an American citizen I just want to see
what they're talking about
you know I I'm not a Muslim I've been
invited to a service and I just want to
check it out and he just looked at me
like like with disgusting it was just
like
okay whatever here I'll sign it take
your slip go
and so Friday came
and I was I didn't know what to expect
I've never been to Germany before I
didn't know what they were gonna do
and so I get there and
the Christians meet
at the same time but they go to another
room so the Christians were there and
the Muslims that were there at the at
the guard at the guard post
and
the people that were going to Juma all
got strip searched and I mean completely
naked and when the Christians came
through for their Bible study oh go
ahead go through and I just thought
okay what's that all about
and so
we went into the multi-purpose room
and the first thing that I experienced
of Islam
was the Adan
so the brother was just like but Allah
and I just
oh
my God
what and and he the brother was calling
the Adan
and I asked Omar I said what is that
beautiful song that this man is singing
and he said yeah it's not a song
um he's he's calling people to to prayer
that's what we do
and I just said wow they call people to
prayer
they don't call Christians into prayer
you know they uh all they want is they
they call you to pay pay your tithes
they don't call you to prayer so he said
okay let me take you inside and uh teach
you how to make wudu
and I made wudu for my first time
I met Juma as a non-muslim as a mushrik
and so I heard that on
and we're making wudu now and I'm
thinking
these people
are performing a ritual purification
for none other than God none other than
the respect of God
and I just thought
wow yes yes this is what I want
this is what this is what Christianity
is supposed to be I mean going to the
church there's no concept
you you just show up and I just thought
wow that's okay another thing that's
that I'm impressed with so it started
with that you were fascinated with that
now we get into the uh purify the
evolution we do and just keeps getting
better huh
keeps on getting better
and so we went to the main prayer Hall
in the multi-purpose room
and he said let me just it was before
James I just let me like break it down
for you what's going to happen he said
basically it's like Sunday church except
we're gonna sit on the floor and the
Imam or the pastor is going to
um speak a little bit about Islam he's
got like a little message or a sermon
and uh then we're all going to stand up
and he is going to we're going to pray
we're going to read from the Quran and I
said um okay
um so
you guys stand up or does he read the
Quran to you when he prays or what
he said no no we all line up in One
Direction
and by the way
um this Imam he doesn't
um read from the Quran he actually has
the entire Quran memorized
I said Omar now
that book that you gave me that that
book that you gave me that's in myself
that this book he memorized the whole
the whole chapter I mean the whole book
he said
um it's not strange millions of Muslims
have the Quran memorized uh and and
millions and millions and hundreds of
millions all the way from the time of
the Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam there will always be people
that memorize the Quran and that right
there was just like
okay
these people are no jokes they are not a
joke they memorize
the Quran the whole book
it means that they care about the book
it means that the translation can't be
lost it means people can't say anything
about the Quran like they say in the
Bible
it the Quran is the Quran and that's it
so I was that was like it like like you
say it just kept on getting better like
well I'm in the right place Uh
something's about to happen I know it
and so long story short
we sat there and we listened to the
khutba and it came to the time for us to
get up and pray for them to get up and
pray because remember I'm still not a
Muslim and I didn't even go there with
the purpose of becoming a Muslim I just
wanted to see
so
Omar told me look could you like sit
over there by the side we're going to
all line up in rows and we're going to
pray so just watch us and then we'll
talk to you later
I said fine
so
these big big muscular you know Killers
thugs gangster ex-gangsters ex-killers
Exodus extra
Imam said Allahu Akbar
and I saw a change in all
of the Muslims face and their demeanor
they just
they all became humble in front of Allah
and I was just like
oh you're observing you're sitting from
the side observing you're not actually
taking part in the prayer yet just watch
I'm not I'm not in the prayer I'm just
sitting on the side yeah close to the
close to the second row just like
okay and I'm listening to the the Imam
recite the Quran and I was just like
whoa whoa whoa okay it's something's
like it's taken off it's getting better
and better
and I decided you know he told me to sit
there
but no I was there for answers
I was looking for God
I wanted to find God I was looking for
God my whole life
and you know the Quran the wudu the the
truth of the Quran no I I I'm here for
answers so I got I got up
and I went to the side of the front row
and I did one of these I was like
I I looked at their face in the front
row I I didn't care I was there for
answers I just wanted to see them
and they were just they were lost they
they weren't lost they were lost
in the love and the Adoration
of Allah and I just thought
oh
but if anybody wants to ask me
Ali what did it for you
what made you become a Muslim
how did Allah
open your heart to Islam
it was none other than the moment when
these prisoners
these Muslims
made sujud
that was it the prostration
watching them pray like Jesus prayed
right when I saw this it's it's almost
like you know when you get into cold
water you say
like it was overwhelming they called
each other
to the worship of Allah they had washed
their hands and their feet and their
face and their arms they had recited the
holy book they
are humbled in front of their lord and
now they put their faces on the ground
it was at that point where Islam became
completely
irresistible
completely irresistible and I had to
have it
and I decided right there I'm going to
become a Muslim you made that decision
up until then did you did you know about
the six articles of Faith the Five
Pillars the pure monotheism the worship
of one and only one God Prophet Muhammad
being a the final messenger and a line
of Messengers was this all clear to you
absolutely crystal but I didn't make the
commitment I I didn't go to Juma to
become a Muslim I just wanted to see
what they did so after the jummah Omar
came up to me I had sat back down and
Omar said so what do you think
and I said Omar I said something out of
ignorance and this is the ignorance of a
lot of white Americans I said something
foolish
out of ignorance I said
I don't know I don't see any white
people in Islam but but you have to make
an exception for me I'm going to become
a Muslim today and I'm not leaving until
I you teach me or you accept me or show
me the way how to be a Muslim you're
going to make it this you're going to
make a uh consideration for me
and all of the all of the Muslim
brothers were like Allah Allah
and uh Omar said now
you can become a Muslim right now and I
just
you know I lit up like I can I can and
we all sat in a uh in a circle in 1991
and October
and I said
that was it you took your shahada your
testimony of faith and you can submitter
one who submits his will to the creator
of heavens and earth a Muslim
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah I did
alhamdulillah and you've been making
videos and I want to get into one of
those videos because this is something
that is crystal clear that it goes with
the human nature that God is one and a
long worthy of worship human beings go
ahead and take creation is worship The
Messengers call people to call people
back to Croatia to worship the creator
of creation God Almighty the Creator
Allah and Aramaic Allah this is the same
God and we even have uh so much evidence
and proof you know a lot of times you'll
see these uh ads come up sometimes and
someone will talk about how they came
towards uh Jesus they saw a dream an
emotional experience
but you have so much evidence you know
and you have so much proof and one of
those proof you discuss or you're you're
commenting on and I want you to react to
this here in this video about Prophet
Muhammad even being in the Bible because
in the Bible before I dive into Bible
Hub I need to show you this thing that
Muslims believe Muslims believe that the
prophet was in a cave of Hira and the
Angels Came to him and asked him to read
the prophet replied I don't know how to
read
now if you go to Isaiah 29 12 here's
what it says it says I can't be making
this up it says then the book will be
given to the one who is illiterate
saying please read this and he will say
I cannot read now it gets crazier now
look at this now keep in mind that's
what the current version of the Bible
says I wonder what the most authentic
version of the Bible would say about
this verse like maybe there's more
context we don't know so if you go to
the oldest version of the Bible okay
here's the website all right let's go
let's go to Isaiah all right so here it
is I'm just gonna zoom in this literally
doesn't get any more authentic than this
literally okay watch this now the most
authentic version says something
different yeah I want you guys to pay
attention to this look at how it's all
uppercase very nicely organized but then
it looks like someone scribbled in an e
there and someone scribbled in a c there
it doesn't look like that was meant to
be there it looks like it was supposed
to be x-i-p-a because look at how
squished the E is here but not here like
all the other letters are perfectly
spaced out but with this one it looks
like someone just put in an E and A C I
think it was supposed to be x-i-p-a
let's let's look at Hebrew what x-i-p-a
means okay let's look what happens and
there it is look I'm gonna click play
listen very careful listen to how it
sounds like
Hira oh my goodness guys the first
Miracles that in the Bible it literally
says the book will be given to the one
who is illiterate saying please read
this and you'll say I cannot read this
this is literally what Muslims believe
like the Bible is telling you that the
the forethcoming of prophet Muhammad
peace of blessings be upon him when you
give up more context you literally can
literally see okay that it's being
squished and someone put an E and A C
it's not a big look look at all the
other letters look at how all spaced out
it is look this is look how this e looks
like why doesn't that E look like that
look at how this he looks like why
doesn't Matty look like that looks like
someone forced it so when you put
x-i-p-a how it's supposed to look like
guess what guess what it says the
context of this is that it's in the cave
of Hira the same thing that Muslims
believe the prophet was in the cave of
Hira revealing this revelation
uh so you verified this uh you you
shared this I mean this was a talk uh go
ahead and unpackage that what were you
thinking and what was the what was the
strong message that's coming from this
look the message is this to the
Christians
um I
I don't know exactly how to unpack it
all I know to say is
to the Christian our brothers and
Humanity that are watching this
um
Islam is much older at what you think
the message of the prophets
are not different
there is not different types
of religions except dietary laws like
you know the Jews have the kosher we
have Halal and and and that's about it
but the message of Jesus
is the same all of the all of the
prophets are brothers all of them are
telling you throughout you know the 124
000 prophets that Allah
the same thing all throughout creation
God is one God is one come to prayer
give sadaka treat your fellow man right
and this is just a proof I have many
other uh videos that talk about this and
my my message is this to the Christians
you just don't know
I have been a Muslim I I was your
brother
I was your son I was your colleague for
19 years of my life
I know Christianity
left right and Center I know it inside
and out I was one of you
and now I'm a Muslim I am a person that
knows both sides of the coin you do not
know both sides of the coin
when somebody wants to learn about
Christianity who do they go to
they go to a priest they go to a pastor
when somebody wants to know about
Judaism where do they go naturally to a
rabbi
but I find it
sad that when the world wants to know
about Islam Unfortunately they go to
well-known islamophobes they search
about why is Islam untrue I I don't want
to know if it is true I don't want to
know anything about it it can't be true
right it can't because that's a religion
of violence right Islam can't be true
and so
unfortunately the Christians get this
thing in their mind that Islam is this
and that's all I need to know oh thank
God that Islam is not true well
I hold that thought for a minute
um
don't say thank God so easily because
Islam is the fastest growing religion in
the world
and there is a reason for that
there is a reason why probably one of
your sons
maybe even in nice maybe even your
husband
has left Christianity and become a
Muslim there is a reason why twenty
thousand Christians in America alone
we're just talking about America become
Muslim every single year and it's not
because of violence it's not because of
Oppression it's because it's true it's
because the Quran has been preserved and
it proves itself time and time again
that is why so my message to the
Christian listeners out there you really
need to humble yourself and stop
learning Islam from the people that are
combating Islam and ask us watch the
dean show go to you know uh uh you know
any any Islamic you know reputable
Islamic site and learn Islam I promise
you when you're exposed to the Real
Islam the authentic Islam
it's hard for me to say that you would
turn it away because when I experience
Islam
it was irresistible I I cannot imagine
myself not being a Muslim yeah
Allah keep my heart to the religion of
of Allah
I I cannot imagine living in any other
way so Christians please all I'm asking
give Islam a chance and learn it from an
authentic Source I'm begging you great
advice a couple more questions before we
conclude yeah this is amazing this video
because there's so much proof signs upon
signs evidence upon evidence and just in
here this uh this mountain that's
mentioned the cave Hira it's there and
it seemed like they were doing something
with the the text there or the I don't
know what he was saying with the what
they changing they tried to change it or
something or they snuck you know they
snuck in a letter to change the sound of
Hira so that's that's the whole point
they snuck it that's the point okay they
try to put in something to change it but
when you go ahead and you listen to it
this is the the cave that the the
Revelation came to Prophet Muhammad and
then there's others uh signs there
there's just too many it's not
coincidence it's uh is somebody sincere
and they're humble uh they're
open-minded and then they observe of the
the message the message makes sense
worship one God one God alone uh the the
confirmation that Jesus was a messenger
clarifying who he was who he wasn't and
how to run your life how to run your
family how to run a country everything
is there
uh laid out
in Islam it's just uh too much too much
uh for one man to go ahead and come up
on his own it's not possible it's
impossible and you have this Quran is a
living miracle
and it's there and you've beautifully
stated how you know both sides of the
coin so this is great advice look at the
other side and don't go to the
professional islamophobes who get paid
for bashing Islam uh come to the
qualified sources to go ahead and learn
and make your decision from there like
you did I mean it's one more point I
mean Islam is so clear like you were
saying it's it's so easy to understand
easy uh we Muslims out of the three
abrahamic faiths that is Islam Judaism
and Christianity you know the Muslims
say
the Jews say hear you Israel the Lord
your God is one and so the Jews and the
Muslims we agree with each other as far
as uh you know God
but when the Christians say oh wait a
minute we we believe in one God too
and you know show what's in the Bible
where God said or Jesus said that he's
God well this one verse I am
that I am and you know that's what turns
me away from Christianity
Islam is so clear Judaism is so clear
about God why can't Christianity be so
clear and why is it just full of riddles
I am that I am no we want to see we want
to read I jesus am God but it does not
exist in the Bible and the problem is
the Christians have ticketed upon
themselves to
appoint themselves as much as mufaserin
people that have have this self annoying
self-appointed power to pick apart and
translate the meanings of the Bible when
they have no right to do so I mean in
Christianity reading the Bible
um first of all they'll tell you
um if you don't read the but if you
don't understand the Bible that means
that you don't have the Holy Spirit and
so I made a video called the Father the
Son and the Holy Segway because they
always use the Holy Spirit as a segue oh
you don't understand well you didn't
know Jesus that way that's why you don't
understand the Bible and this is you
think it's a contradiction you're not
reading it with the Holy Spirit and I'm
thinking this is not a religion and and
I did another video about you know the
Council of Isaiah how they decided what
Christianity was and what it wasn't and
you know what my question is why isn't
Christianity so clear why when Judaism
is and Islam is the ultimate Clarity of
what we should be doing and how we
should be believing
tell me how did your father take to it
is um is he someone who is is he still
part of your life did he when he found
out is how did he take to it what was
his reaction
I um
wrote a letter to my my two half
brothers and my one half sister
telling them
how I became a Muslim and why I wrote a
letter to my my
father as well
and
so they got the letter and I I just
called my father
excuse me
I called my father
and
instead of saying hello
he said you son of don't you ever ever
tell you know your your brothers and
your sister about this Islam nonsense of
course he didn't say nonsense I'm just
you know a bunch of explicitives
and and and and you're no son of mine
and blah blah blah and so it kind of
settled down and
I said uh but he actually threatened me
and he said listen
it's either Islam or it's us and
remember I told you that I've I've been
raised like
very very well off and
he said you know your inheritance I said
yes he said you know that the house you
know the house and the land and
everything
I said yes sir
he said you know
if you persist
and this Islam nonsense
I will go to my lawyer tomorrow
and I will write you out of my will and
you will have absolutely nothing wow so
he's threatening you with the
inheritance now that's it all the money
is going to be gone no more wealth and
I'm not I'm not I'm not saying that I'm
not going to say the the number but it
was it was six figures and it was a huge
house and it was land on that house
and
he said you know he gave me an ultimatum
and I said immediately I choose Islam
you said wow
by the time he finished his sentence I
said I choose Islam
and he said
okay
so before you become dead to me
and penniless
I want to know why I gotta have some
closure as to why
and I said dad look
you're my father
whether you're pleased or you're not
pleased with me I'm your son
pleased with me whether I'm a Muslim
whether I'm a Jew or a Christian
I can obey you on every single aspect of
my life and I have
but when it comes to matters
or the hereafter
when it comes
to the day of judgment which by the way
is a day which Dad I can't say anything
for you and you can't say anything from
me
I will answer and I will be in front of
of God the almighty just like you will
and I won't be swayed by all the money
in the world
I can't
this is something that I've been looking
for my whole life
and I finally found it
and God is the one that provides for me
anyway
God is the one that created me
and so I rely on God 100 percent
so do you respectfully
do what you got to do
you will find that I will be a Muslim
and I have
become a Muslim and I will stay a Muslim
and I will die a Muslim
and he did just that he went to this
lawyer the next day
sent me a copy that I was completely out
of his will and I said I looked at the
letter and I said alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah that Allah
out of my whole lineage which comes from
Norway
out of my whole lineage
I am the only one
that Allah
has chosen to give edaya
and so
I have everything
if I don't have Islam
and I have a million dollars
what do I have
I have nothing but I have if I have
Allah you know I have everything I have
salvation to live in this Earth for
another week or two or a couple of years
or 30 years whatever Allah decides for
me at least yeah that I could die insha
Allah
on my lips
and return to my Lord with him being
pleased with me isn't that everything
isn't that the ultimate victory Of My
Life becoming a Muslim and having Allah
please with me and dying upon Islam
total Victory the ultimate Victory so
alhamdulillah I'm I'm
I'm I'm very content with my life with
what's happened to me and the greatest
thing that's ever happened to my life is
that I became a slave of Allah
that's it
so your family originally from Norway
well my grandfather immigrated from
Norway yeah from Norway I see uh so the
last couple of Viking Viking lineage
Viking lineage you got Viking lineage uh
so I heard a lot of Vikings also uh in
some of the coins I've seen you've seen
some writing from
some Arabic calligraphy there have you
seen some of these they say some some of
the Vikings might have uh come over to
Islam
yeah the uh the the Rings as well they
were buried with the Rings and there's
some tapestry that fake Vikings were you
know actually uh IBN fadlan he he you
know I don't know if you've seen the
movie 13th Warrior that's actually a
real book that it was based off of and
uh the Vikings and the Muslims they did
meet uh on the Volga River and um they
they actually clashed with the I believe
it was the omaid Abbasid I can't
remember but they actually clashed at
andalus with the with the Vikings and
they the Muslims actually lost on the
first encounter but the second encounter
they were the only ones that actually
defeated the Vikings and so the Khalifa
at that time
he said he saw an opportunity
he said here's some people
that are like Warriors
I can use them so he actually came to
one of The Chieftains of the Vikings and
said
um
you guys want a job
and the Vikings were like yeah what's up
is there gold in it yeah so basically
the job was Patrol
but you know come under our Authority
you don't have to become Muslims but
Patrol our Coastline from Portugal all
the way down to the Moroccan Coast all
the way to Sicily and back and just
protect our Coastline and the Viking
said okay but not only that a lot of
them became there's two two towns in uh
I believe Portugal or southern Spain
that that are are known are Viking a lot
of Vikings settled there and they became
Muslim so
wow
this amazing guy so when you were
studying the Bible in Bible study did
you know that Matthew didn't write
Matthew did you had a lot of these
Anonymous books did you know any of that
none of it we were never told that this
is this is
the book of God and and don't question
the book of God I never knew any of this
stuff they never teach you that no and
now I'm pretty sure I want to just show
one of the the Miracles and how the
Quran is uh preserved and you've been a
Muslim now for how many years said 30.
31 years this October will be 32 years
and every Muslim is aspiring to memorize
the Quran bits of it chunks of it the
whole of it and if I ask you now to
recite any part of the Quran uh one that
identifies who God Almighty for example
you'd go ahead and if you can recite
that for us because this defines who it
shows how the Quran is preserved someone
who's not a native arabic speaking
person not an Arab you're an American
formerly Christian now Muslim and it's
just like somebody asking you to recite
something original that Jesus might have
had in Aramaic but we don't have
anything original or the sister language
the Aramaic is Arabic so would you would
you go ahead and uh I'll put you sorry
put you on a spot but can you recite
this for us and this actually defines
who God is in this very short chapter of
the Quran
absolutely and this is to the Christian
viewers this is another proof that if I
recite this wrong
automatically Eddie will say oh what
wasn't it wait a minute you made a
mistake on this one word that is a
miracle in itself if I were to read the
Bible and I said a different wording or
a different meaning no Christian would
stop me they would think um okay but
with the Quran
I am not a native Arabic speaker I'm
Norwegian I'm an American
um but if when I recite the Quran when I
recite sort of
people will either say yes you have
recited it correctly word for word
letter for letter or they will say no
brother you have made a mistake and with
that
Bismillah
foreign
so in here uh what does that actually
mean what did you say what's the meaning
here what
say that Allah is one
the unique Allah
Allah the eternal
he was never he was never born nor does
he give birth
and there is none like him or comparable
to him as Allah says in the Quran
there is nothing comparable to Allah
although he sees and he hears
mashallah thank you very much and we'll
conclude with that thank you for uh
being with us here sharing your
wonderful story if you want to get in
touch with you they want to see some of
your videos how can they uh connect with
you
yeah I have uh Tick Tock
um Maliki click same name on this video
um and I have YouTube Maliki click as
well
and I don't know if if you allowed me to
to plug my patreon inshallah could I do
that or sure go ahead okay so you can if
you want to help the dawa out uh you can
you can help me out that on uh with a
monthly subscription on patreon
backslash Maliki click I sure would
appreciate it I mean the Jews get behind
the Jews and the Christians get behind
the Christians even the islamophobes get
behind the islipes and they support them
so I'm requesting you know for you to uh
to help me out as well as Eddie as as
well as all the days inshallah so uh
patreon Maliki click you can really help
me out I appreciate it and I have to say
I was
raised in Islam basically on this show
this show is priceless it's valuable it
needs to be supported uh and I just
can't believe that I'm actually here
with you brother I love you for the sake
of Allah and it's such an honor to be on
your show
thank you brother thank you so much may
Allah continue to bless you and use this
a source of goodness for so many people
who are listening watching this story
that they can also reflect upon it and
inshallah come to the truth like you did
amen thank you very much enjoyed
listening to your story amazing amazing
thank you brother thank you
and so what you got to hear was this is
the verbatim word of God Almighty Allah
the Quran and if you go to the
deanshow.com I'll get you a free copy a
gift from me to you and if you have any
questions
don't be shy go ahead and call
1-800-662 Islam that's 1-800-662-islam
we'll go ahead and answer your questions
clear up the doubts and we'll see you
next time here on the dean show until
then peace be with you assalamu alaikum
to my dear brothers and sisters in Islam
listen if you want an opportunity to
support dawah if you get this this is
the project for you to do that I'm
saying to you very clearly you know
whether it's a dollar or whether it's a
million dollars this is the project that
you need to support so we can have a
template you know for dawa and a
community and we need to ask Allah to
duplicate this here ten times All Over
America
speaking to you from the dean dawa
center in Tampa Florida